there's rumor that there's a new
housewife it cannot confirm or deny
nikki has her own hour at the end this
will be their first look at life in
dubai first of all i have to give some
props to season 15. kovid was happening
several of them got it
anderson says you said in the book that
he says you throw parties like a
housewives reunion yes that's true that
makes my heart so happy yes so you kind
of get messy a little bit i can i mean i
like to
have the intrigue of oh i'm throwing the
party and she's coming and you know who
else is coming
he's coming yeah and what's going to
happen was there like a 366
that you said oh this just
yeah there were i mean there were a lot
of quotes now as i do press i i was on
the view the other day and joy behar was
like i should be in this book and i was
like you should be in this yeah someone
who cares so maybe
maybe the next one yeah yeah she def
that so what who cares is definitely a
thing with her but i yeah when i when i
was reading it i found myself thinking
of like quotes especially because i'm a
big housewives fan especially from like
iconic things from them that and some of
them i didn't see close your legs to
marry men close your legs to married men
i thought i thought that might mean yeah
that might be in there don't come for me
unless i sin for you don't come for me
unless i sinned for you i thought that
was that was a really good one and i
steal
one from heather dubrow all the time
that i say in life this is low-based
bull this is low it is face [ __ ]
that's like my face that's good it's one
of my favorite things
that's a dirty low down monkey with a
wig on and that kim's a low down monkey
with a wig on that one
can we do a little housewives roundup
sure okay let's do that because there's
a lot going on first things first i have
never been so happy to end up on the
cutting room floor of a show i shot with
garcelle last season on beverly hills oh
honey you had so much content like if
that would have made it
no oh i'm upset now no no no no it was
fun it was a lot of fun but
like you had so much content i love that
the
cameras are right back up and rolling
yes
i mean it kind of had to so when you
have something like what happened to
darite yeah how does that shake up
what's going on in the season or kind of
well i mean
you have to watch and see i mean we're
following their real lives when
something like that happens all you can
do is follow
the action i haven't seen her we've
communicated i'm so glad she and her
family are okay and by all accounts she
handled it like a champ i can't even
imagine what i would have done they had
the video today of you saw some of the
men like dragging you know
the purses or whatever all of that stuff
out um but but of course i mean you
always say these these shows aren't
scripted so this is real life and yeah
you know presumably we're going to see
this play out on the season correct
there's rumor that there's a new
housewife she was in a picture selena i
cannot confirm okay nor did i is she a
madam a madam that's what the word was
really that's when the word that i
hadn't heard no wow okay okay okay all
right can you if she were that would be
interesting can you tease anything
what's great is the reunion ended
with
a lot still happening this will not be
wrapped up easily it is a long arduous
process and all i can do is put one foot
in front of the other you had
relationships that were still in flux
and so i think the fact that we got
right away shooting is great because we
we're picking up right where the drama
left off have you heard feedback like
lately that you have taken your reunion
game to another level thank you
seriously i felt like oh andy wasn't
playing with the children beverly hills
okay he's like no no no i'm not standing
for any of the messages well i will say
i haven't told anyone but i think that
beverly hills was one of my
favorite reunions to do only because i
was so
i mean listen i love talking about a
disagreement about
placement at a table at a dinner party
but
this was something that i had such
curiosity about and there were questions
that hadn't been asked and hadn't been
answered do you think you went far in
the other direction to protect him
on this show i think that i highlighted
the best of him why didn't you leave tom
sooner where was i going where weren't
you going you're on a hit tv show you
have a career hold on and i was thrilled
to be able to get there to sit there and
ask them all
and uh she took us on a wild ride
she was emotional she was angry uh she
was unrepentant and i think the viewers
were
shocked by her attitude and they were
expecting or demanding one thing and
many felt that they didn't get what they
wanted from her but it was her truth and
she walked away i know feeling great
about it so there you go we get a whole
new accent remember i know that that's
right yeah like there's been some erica
jargon but i'm just who is this person
it's only in beverly hills that
everybody's so precious
now we are not in surry county but is
surry county
in you
always sarri's always in me yes thank
you
very good
thank goodness that folks are coming to
the potomac party now because those
ladies have given us they have since
season one yeah four parts is there a
whole nicki minaj hour yes there is
nikki has her own hour at the end
[Music]
[Applause]
you'll see her come in and surprise the
women at the end of part three
and they're
stunned and they're even more stunned
when she sits down with her pink cards
with questions that she wrote herself
and many opinions i went to nikki before
and i said listen i try to stay neutral
and i try to kind of service as many
opinions as i can you
can go in there and do your thing
and share your opinions and she does
yeah giselle and robin have a podcast
and they were talking about it on the
podcast right and kind of ranking who
they thought like were her favorites to
their least favorites so they said they
felt like maybe she was flirting with
robin a little bit okay she kind of had
a little affinity for robin she liked
karen then the next tier was maybe wendy
mia and giselle then candace and then
ashley was the one she likes to leave
she went for ashley she went for ashley
but by the way she went for giselle too
i don't know if gisele brought that up
well you said it she's teflon like it
just rolls off yes but she she did go
for giselle she did i think there were
things that she was saying that as a fan
and not a producer and someone who's
trying his best to be neutral or at
least ask the questions that the
audience once answered i think that
just her sitting there as a fan there
were things that she was saying that i
wouldn't have said right and i wouldn't
have been able to say right and then i
think that there were things that as a
woman of color
she was able to say that i wasn't able
to say i came out at the end and i said
wow you said you said stuff that i never
would have been able to say and she said
why and robin said because he's a white
man
and that's the truth you know that is
the truth get your passports our 11th
city we are going to the billionaires
playground the city of gold the desert
oasis the real housewives of dubai we
have a great group of friends this is
going to blow the lid off the entire
franchise on the today show the other
day you announced the real housewives of
dubai yes i didn't see that one coming i
i yeah well good
no one saw potomac coming either i mean
that was a that was a curveball as well
no but this is exciting this is our
first international
housewives produced for bravo by bra
right
and uh we've got a great group of women
and
we're getting underway
right now now the internet loves to
weigh in yeah so there is like
conjecture thinking could some of the
laws that people may think are
restrictive there like hinder
you from having the drama that we love
in-house well i think that'll be
something that'll be interesting to see
and i think for a lot of people this
will be their first look at life in
dubai and granted it will be a look
inside you know a a very wealthy part of
dubai uh which is by the way a
billionaire's playground on its own the
opulence aren't yeah yes but what i hope
also is that we can
shed some light on what's going on there
culturally
and politically
and maybe we can inform people as we're
entertaining them now beyonce's internet
also says that they believe
caroline stanberry will be on that show
i can't say anything about the cast but
i understand why people think that
and we'll see if that comes to be she
doesn't live there anymore though right
she lives in la or i mean she i believe
she does she still lives there yeah
i loved her own ladies of london she was
my favorite so it would be great to see
her come back it would be so orange
county is up next yeah
all right you told us uh you know during
the kind of off period that you
understood the assignment yeah that you
knew
what had to be done yes to do to this
franchise yeah so what were the boxes
that you checked first of all i have to
give
some props to season 15. that was really
wrong of me and i want to own up to that
and i apologize we started shooting i
think in february of 2020. yeah we were
shut down so many times covid was
happening several of them got it yeah it
was not a fun season it was not a
particularly aspirational season um i
think that there was a lot of politics
that were involved orange county being
more open
and it is with the return of heather
dubrow and with some of the new
housewives
there is a sense of affluence and a
sense of escapism that the viewers are
looking for heather has a connection to
women on the show to shannon certainly
yes and you see how it plays out with
emily and gina in often hilarious and
often dramatic ways and so it's when i
watched it i watched the fourth episode
today i was like
i'm watching rhoc this is the show i've
always loved it feels like it and it's
great and so i just feel like great i
can we can tip this off our boxes of
this is great this show is set we're all
good finally getting a peach marlo
hampton yes before you said she never
got a peach because there was not a
consensus in the room did someone leave
the room to become a consensus or did
just video i think it was a combination
of things i think that she had built
real relationships with the women over
the years she was a monty which i think
added a level of depth to her personal
story
that um we maybe hadn't seen before
and we had a great curiosity about
seeing that the money i spent maybe they
make you defend me darling the way
you're able to light up you could never
model
ever be our tour guide
and then there was an incredible fan
groundswell
of people who just wanted this to happen
so and it just happened at the right
time
i have to ask you about nene yeah he was
on a talk show the other day
would you return yes nene
uh yeah sure i'll return to the show i
think that andy and i uh need to have a
sit down and talk and then we're off to
the races would you be open to something
like that you know what right now we're
i'm right now i'm so focused on this
season which is in production and we've
got a great group
and we're often running to the races so
right now my mind is really okay on that
i got you yeah oh my god let me take
this
[ __ ] thing off
is roni in repair mode or rhony is in
pause mode and it will be in repair mode
and listen roni's another one you talk
about you know we talked about the
season of oc that people didn't love
this last season of new york was a
season that wasn't people's favorite all
right guys
ready yes do you think there's a toilet
here but again it was shot during coven
we went to salem massachusetts it's
probably a place we wouldn't have gone
in other seasons we went to ramona's
house
quite a lot yeah and so you know we're
looking forward to next season and just
building on it and we're it's a fun
problem to have yes how do we make a
great show better and that's what we're
working on you kind of have an
embarrassment of riches right now on
your franchises and then you're also
bringing miami back that's peacock which
is great
i mean bring larissa pippin back and you
got a story right there yes we did that
girl is the story in hershey she is does
she talk about the kardashians at all
there are some kardashian references
okay and uh she's at an interesting
stage in her life her
marriage is ending yeah her kids are
growing
and she's kind of
got a new thing happening and it's
really interesting to watch last
question teresa's engaged yes will we
see this one play out on bravo will you
know already i've just seen the first
episode of jersey and it is a doozy are
you saying that she was wrong to spread
the rumor um never go against the family
teresa's relationship is at center stage
could i don't even know how you keep
winning in jersey i mean it just whoever
you are it's a win it's a great group we
had a few off years where we were trying
to figure things out i feel very blessed
that we've been able to
with a lot of care
keep this franchise going uh in so many
cities for so many years
you